#HASHTAGWARS.
(APPLAUSE)
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO THIS.
>> Chris: LET'S TEST OUR
SHORT-TERM MEMORIES.
TODAY ON REDDIT, A USER SAID
HIS FRIEND ORDERED TWO TICKETS
TO SEE THE RED HOT CHILI
PEPPERS, BUT FOR HIS $228
HE RECEIVED TWO TICKETS TO SEE
THE RED HOT CHILI PIPERS,
"BAGPIPERS WHO ROCK"
AND WHOSE NAME IS CONFUSING.
COMEDIANS, WITH THAT IN MIND,
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS:
#KNOCKOFFBANDS.
EXAMPLES: HUEY LEWIS AND THE FOX
NEWS, OR THE NEW BEATLES,
OR BLINK-181.
I'M PUTTING 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, YOU GUYS ARE GONNA GET
YOUR ANSWERS READY, SET, GO!
BETH?
>> THE PENISY CHICKS.
>> Chris: OH, INSTEAD OF THE
DIXIE CHICKS?
I LOVE IT.
POINTS.
RORY SCOVEL?
>> POSSIBLY GIANTS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
WELL DONE.
BETH STELLING?
>> BRITNEY WHOLE-PICKLE.
NOT JUST A SPEAR.
>> Chris: I LIKE THE IDEA
OF BRITNEY WHOLE-PICKLE.
POINTS.
YES, JON DORE?
>> OKAY, BIT OF EXPLANATION.
>> Chris: GOOD, WE HAVE 15
SECONDS.
>> A GROUP OF HOMELESS MEN
PERFORMING RUSH SONGS AND IT'S
CALLED "BUM RUSH THE SHOW."
(LAUGHING)
>> CAREFUL.
(BUZZER)
>> Chris: THAT WAS A FARTHER
JOURNEY THAT YOU GETTING HERE
FROM CANADA.
POINTS, WELL DONE.